to me the most important behaviors are
to have an insatiable curiosity but it's
not just enough to be passively curious
you have to put into action and you have
to be passionate about problem solving
and then you have to be Fearless about
risk which means that you Embrace change
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with Lorraine Martin executive
managing director of meritive formerly
IBM Watson Health she has three decades
of experience in new product development
and has held leadership positions at
Bristol Myers Squibb kovins cognizant
and iqvia and has co-founded four
companies Martin is an adjunct professor
of management and serves on the
healthcare and pharmaceutical Management
program Advisory board at Columbia
business school and is an Adjunct
professor of innovation and
Entrepreneurship at Yeshiva University's
cats School of Science and health she is
also an investor member of venture from
Plum Alley her new book The Innovation
mindset eight essential steps to
transform any industry was recently
published by Columbia University press
we're gonna have such a good time
Lorraine so much to get through so
little time 20 minutes is not nearly
enough
you have so many different hats such in
and such amazing experiences that that
I'm just excited to pick your brain on
the different things that that you've
uncovered the different things that
you're you're excited about ultimately
you know thinking about Innovation and
most recent book The Innovation mindset
and I'd love to understand how this
plays into your life all the way from
from your parents and from your
upbringing to date with your teachings
with Yeshiva University in Colombia
you've also taught in some other
incredible institutions like Princeton
and Rutgers you co-founded a bunch of
companies you you're involved with a
narrative formerly IBM Watson health so
so much so many different things to to
talk about that it's a little bit
overwhelming as a host here but I'll do
my best uh Lorraine you know put some
sense into all these different things
that I just said how how does that
happen what's sort of the connecting Dot
for your own path as you see it oh well
thank you Michael for that question and
it is a circuitous path and I'll I'll
try to cut through and make it simple
for people to understand what makes me
tick so to speak and so I'll tell two
stories uh the first story is you you
know you reference my upbringing and my
parents and I did have the Good Fortune
to be reared by mom and a dad but my dad
in particular was an inventor and
growing up around the house he would
always challenge me and my younger
brother to find at least three solutions
to every problem that we identified
and he really brought this point home
one summer when he took us to the hot
shops cafeteria a diner in uh the
outskirts of a little city in Maryland
and our job is we sat in the big red
vinyl booths of the diner eating our
breakfast of scrambled eggs and orange
juice was to observe what was slowing
down table turnover
and he got us a stopwatch we had our
composition books our three colored pens
he even made sure that we could
interview the waitresses and the bus
boys he obviously led the interviews and
after three days of research we
determined that the culprit was sugar
packets and as individuals we're putting
the sugar in their copy of their tea
they were
spewing them on the floor it was just
taking extra many extra minutes to clean
wow but but my dad because you always
had to come up with three solutions we
didn't stop there
so we had the job of coming up with
three solutions and we did
and the one that we landed on and ended
up taking to prototype was something
that we called the sugar cube and it
held the sugar packets also the
discarded ones and then to make sure
that it had value Beyond just a sugar
packet dispenser we designed it so that
it could hold advertising and the local
advertisers could put their
advertisements absolutely at the diner
so when we unveiled it to the manager of
the restaurant she locked it and I'm not
um I'm not being exaggerating with that
she really loved it and she loved it so
much that she spread the word throughout
the Baltimore Washington area within six
months the sugar cube was being used in
these Hot Shot cafeterias so you can
imagine what an amazing experience that
was how old were you I was 13. by the
age of 13 I learned that problem solving
was fun and lucrative and I also learned
a disciplined approach to it I learned
that you had to really understand your
problem you had to quantify you had to
qualify it you had to test it with your
customers and then you had to come up
with the solution that you could also
test for fit and that ultimately your
customer had to be willing to pay for
your new product or solution
so if I kind of fast forward I've always
been interested in health care
my own mission statement has been around
being able to advance and promote
People's Health and early in my career I
found myself at the National Institutes
of Health
and I was a science writer there and I
was watching the amazing work that was
being done in cancer in the sequencing
of the human genome I could see that
biologic therapies and Gene therapies
and and cell therapies at some point
were going to be making their way down
the path and that we would have
Precision medicine as we know it now but
at that time we were in the era of the
Blockbuster drugs so cardiovascular
disease high blood pressure high
cholesterol and in those days they
believe that those diseases were
primarily uh the the the symptoms would
be in in in Men in middle-aged men
so the clinical trial infrastructure the
research infrastructure was primarily
designed to test new drugs and Therapies
in middle-aged white men
and as I saw these Therapies in the
human genome and the possibility of
precision medicine I realized even then
that we were going to need to include
women that we were going to need to you
know different races and that we would
need to make the research Arena much
more Equitable much more accessible to
all if we were really going to create
these wonderful therapies and so I
decided I was going to grab hold a part
of that elephant in my career and tackle
that problem now obviously I couldn't
tackle the whole problem because there
are a lot of different parts of it but
in my quest to try to make Health Care
More Equitable clinical research more
Equitable and get drugs to Market to
help more people
that's really been the guiding principle
that has that has guided my career and
my career choices so when you talk about
all the different things that I've done
it's all been around that as a mission
statement and all trying to create an
ecosystem where students and graduate
students and early stage entrepreneurs
and corporate Executives and so I've sat
in all those different seats in the
ecosystem in an effort to try to
influence them positively about having a
problem-solving orientation and The
Innovation mindset which I write about
in my book that I was fortunate enough
that my dad inculcated in me so I love
the work that I do I love turning people
on to Innovation whether it's a team at
a corporation or senior leaders or
whether it's an individual I got a great
email yesterday from someone who
attended a talk that I gave around
Innovation and he said he was so
inspired and he got a notebook and he
was writing down problem and would I
meet with them and help them flesh out
these problems he had identified and I
said absolutely because whether it's one
person or a hundred people I want to get
the word out
I love it well I'm definitely sharing
that same excitement right now with my
notebook here is that's why sometimes
I'm looking down because this this is
just fascinating and what I find most
intriguing here and besides obviously
um there's a lot of questions that I
have about your own Innovation mindset
and how how you know you help different
people in different parts of their lives
to translate it into actionable items it
sounds like your life is you've had this
huge mission statement you know very
clear to you about what a role you want
to play not just for yourself but for
your community for the industry for the
ecosystem whether it be students whether
it be health care and what that means
can you walk me through some of the
different things you've taken part in
and how if they fit into your misuse
because I and and specifically I want to
understand that and under the context of
sort of this larger question of why you
do what you do so why did you choose to
do those different Endeavors how did
they fit into the bigger puzzle of Wiz
Lorraine on her mission
yes that's a very insightful question
Michael so thank you for asking it and
what I would say is as I had my own
Innovation Journey so a desire to solve
problems and create Solutions so often I
would find that I was taking a lot of
steps a lot of missteps probably made a
lot of mistakes every mistake in the
book proverbial book so to speak and so
through all of those experiences as I
would look back and think about them and
bring new ideas figure out how I could
do kind of a continuous process
Improvement methodology well I did this
and it didn't work out so well so I'm
going to do this a little bit
differently I I realized that I had
talked with a lot of people I had
experienced a lot of case studies I'd
certainly made a lot of mistakes along
the way and so one of my goals is to try
to help the and accelerate the path of
other innovators to get their ideas to
Market and so in the book I have tried
to distill what is the process or the
steps you can follow to be an innovator
to develop your products and ideas how
can you supercharge that if you will and
how can you avoid making some of the
same mistakes that I did so the book is
really an expression of I wish this book
had existed so I had been innovating in
a corporation when I did my various
startups and my first startup it took me
a year to meet everybody that I needed
to meet to raise Capital to figure a lot
of things out and so I don't think that
everybody should have to go through that
painful process and so we do need a
handbook we do need an acceleration
guide and despite the fact that so many
people do Innovation and get involved in
startups I've talked with people and and
they're in the same situation they
figure it out piece by piece you know
their own little journey and so if in my
own small way I can say this was my
experience these are the steps that I
followed that I think make sense I think
that this can accelerate your path to
Market at least give it a try and maybe
I've helped you in in some small way so
that is sort of the thesis that has
brought together whether it's the
students or the corporate Executives or
the principal investigators who've
wanted to do the startup my sharing my
experience so that all of them can
hopefully do it better faster smarter
than I did
I love it so
you know a lot of them people that are
that are listening to this hopefully are
you know they're aiming to be innovators
in their own Community whether they're
young entrepreneurs like myself or or
investors or Executives what are some
common themes
um and this is obviously relating more
directly to the book what are some
common themes that that we should be
thinking of or I could be addressing in
my own mindset my own methodology to
become a better innovator in whatever I
do whether it be in my startup in my
relationships in in my community really
in every in every Endeavor that I choose
to take for myself
well I think that first it starts with
the individual as the innovator so we
have to start with the person and to me
the most important behaviors are to have
an insatiable curiosity but it's not
just enough to be passively curious you
have to put into action and you have to
be passionate about problem solving and
then you have to be Fearless about risk
which means that you Embrace change so
if you take the Curiosity with the
problem solving and the change I think
that embodies the innovator mindset and
I think it's really important that one
not only inculcate those behaviors in
themselves but they lead from a belief
in those values and behaviors as well
and so one of the most important things
to do is to remove failure from your
Lexicon I say replace it with pivot if
you need to change direction if you need
to change strategy do it it doesn't mean
that you've compromised your vision or
your mission but you need to look at
those market dynamics those changes
regulatory constraints you know whatever
it might be that's creating obstacles
and you may need to change direction so
I think that's
um number one
and then
um part and parcel of that is I find so
often that there are different types of
innovation and so you know there's a
really famous hair product called
Rogaine that was created for male
pattern baldness and what so many people
don't know is that Rogaine was actually
first developed by the up John company
as a heart failure medication but in the
clinical trials yeah they saw that the
men with male pattern baldness were
growing hair so the up John company
pivoted the Rogaine implica indication
for male pattern baldness launched
before the the heart condition
indication and I call that kind of
innovation Serendipity they absolutely
got like right and so many of us think
that that's going to be the kind of
innovation we're going to be involved in
but it's a little bit like winning the
lottery it's very alluring but likely it
won't be the kind of innovation we do
the second type of course is very iconic
we think about Edison and Gates and and
um Steve Jobs and we think of Elon Musk
and we think of these big hunt right
transformative Innovations what Apple
Computing did what Uber and Lyft have
been able to do as as unicorns what
Tesla has been able to do are SpaceX and
these are fabulous too but the fact of
the matter is these sort of
transformative disruptive Innovations
are called unicorns for a reason and
they're probably not also the kind of
innovation that you and I are going to
be involved in and so I don't want
people to be discouraged by that I don't
want them to think oh well I'm not going
to be lucky enough to have a
serendipitous Innovation and I'm not
clever enough to be the innovator of
something transformative therefore I'm
just going to put my head down and keep
doing what I'm doing because I think
that the kind of innovation that can
improve the way you work improve
processes you know even make small
changes to things are really value
valuable and I'll just underscore one
final point that I think will be
valuable to your listeners I do see so
many innovators making the same mistake
and that is that and I'll give you a
quick story when I was early in my
Innovation career a colleague and I
licensed to technology out of an Israeli
lab that was a diagnostic for something
called oxidative stress
and it was amazing because it could
measure oxidative stress in any kind of
body tissue but as we got into it we
found out that it could have
implications for heart failure for
Parkinson's Disease multiple sclerosis
even even selecting
um eggs for in vitro fertilization and
the choices became so vast that we ran
out of money the investors got
frustrated with us and I call that kind
of innovation Field of Dreams
and you must movie about putting the
corn the baseball field up to the corn
field build it and they will come and
it's just human nature that we want to
jump to a solution and we get so excited
about the solution we can rush to take
it to Market we can ask the customer
research in a way that buys us us toward
a positive response and 98 of the time
that kind of innovation doesn't actually
end up working because we've missed the
most fundamental step and that is truly
identifying the problem and making sure
that that problem is one that a customer
wants us to pay us wants to pay us to
fix so if I had to impress upon your
listeners anything again based on one of
my hard fought lessons it's that you
don't want to jump to solution you don't
want to do field of innovation type of
innovation that's a problem you
definitely want to start very
fundamentally with being a good Observer
Gathering that evidence about the
problem and people say well how can I
become more problem oriented I don't
even know how to do that and I say get
yourself a notebook and I don't care if
it's electronic notebook or a
composition book every day write down
three problems that you observe you'll
start to become much more aware of
what's around you you'll become more
problem solving or problem
identification oriented and a lot of
times what comes out of that journaling
in another two or three weeks you're
going to see things that you might ask
actually develop into innovations that
are like within your realm to do like
because they're in in your life they're
in your day-to-day so I think that's a
great way to get started on observing
problems and finding things that are
within your own scope to try to fix and
change and go out and change the world I
wish everybody would
I love it right before it
um I thanked you for the time and and I
really do because this has been
wonderful
um you mentioned before a few a few
different important traits for the
individual on the individual side and
insatiable curiosity passionate about
problem solving
um
removing fear from the Lexicon and then
you mentioned that part of the way is to
lead from those beliefs how no give me
your two cents on not not just obviously
there's the whole challenge of how to
harness those tricks yourself but how do
you what does it mean to lead from these
beliefs
well I think the first thing that you
have to do as a leader is create a
really safe environment for your team to
experiment so this idea of abolishing
failure you have to walk that talk and
so I created something on my team that I
call uh failure free Friday
and when we get together as a team I
would say okay I just want everybody to
go around this week and tell me one
thing that you did that didn't work out
and what you learned from it because the
most important thing is to try to learn
from those things that don't work out
and I don't want you to only be
innovating because you think there's a
prize at the end of it and it's going to
be phenomenally successful but I want
innovating and thinking and solving
problems to be part of what you just
naturally do and the only way I can get
you to do that is if I truly remove that
fear of failure and create a very safe
environment for you to experiment
incredible Lorraine thank you so much
for the time and the effort and the
energy and the amazing impact that
you're having I enjoyed this so much and
I'm excited to share this uh watch it
again and share with friends and family
so thank you very very much for spending
this time with me hey good luck on your
continued mission and vision very
inspiring and uh thank you again for the
time
oh Michael was all it was my pleasure
and thank you for asking such terrific
and insightful questions you you made
this easy for me
I appreciate that thank you thank you
very much
[Music]